[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview of first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with the journalist and author
Rachel shabby and the telegraph's chief
political correspondent Camilla Turner
so let's see what's on the front pages
of some of those newspapers for you now
and the Metro has word of a threat from
the former head of the army Lord dannett
that the intelligence community may seek
to replace politicians accused of
compromising National Security as Liz
truss and Zoella bravman have been in
recent days
on the same subject the guardian warns
of a so-called Wild West attitude to
National Security in government
the eye here's Rishi sunak May reverse
his decision not to attend the cop 27
climate Summit in Egypt after criticism
from fellow conservative MPS
the mail reports on a petrol bomb attack
on a facility housing migrants in Dover
amid questions over whether some centers
are safe and sanitary
that story is also the lead item in
tomorrow's times
and on the subject of migrants the
telegraph reports that the government is
planning to house migrants in hotels
alongside the public to try to regain
control of the channel Crossings crisis
according to the financial times
Vladimir Putin's decision to pull out of
the deal that allowed Ukraine to export
millions of tons of grain is likely to
have a catastrophic effect on the poorer
Nations which rely on the supply
the mirror focuses on the growing
pressure on the NHS and says it's facing
its worst winter on record because of
flu covered and staff shortages
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Rachel shabby and Camilla Turner welcome
to you both let's start with the
guardian and their headline there
ministers accused of wild west attitude
to UK's National Security and this is
following on from several breaches that
we've heard about in recent days Rachel
yeah that's right so um The Guardian has
spoken to various uh security sources
and also former officials about the
breaches as you say uh really troubling
security breaches that we've seen over
the last few days reported about uh Liz
truss in her days as foreign secretary
and alsoella bravaman more recently now
the wild west quote is coming from David
Penman who's the head of the
um FDA which is the union that looks
after seniors civil servants and he's
talking about uh a culture essentially
um within government that is sloppy over
security which obviously is incredibly
troubling
um and he's sort of looking at potential
reasons why that would be the case
um you know we've seen throughout the
day people have been saying well is it
incompetence
um is it more of the sort of one rule
for them one rule for the rest of us uh
vibe that we saw with partygate David
Penman is saying they there just isn't
culturally there isn't a government
interest to sort it out and that this is
how they they want to operate they don't
want a degree of scrutiny
um but the piece is also quoting um Bob
kersling who's the former
um senior civil servant and he points
out uh which sounds right to me that
that this kind of breach
um the fact that um reverman uh lost her
job over it and was then rehired several
days later in the same position as Home
Secretary he was saying you know if a
civil servant did that that would be the
end of the road for them for their
career
um and it's really not in any way
acceptable uh that that wouldn't be the
case for a government Minister yes and
Camilla we've got cross-bench peer and
former head of the British army Richard
downitt
um we know now quoted quite a bit in
this uh accused trust and Braverman of
ill-discipline and poor judgment do you
agree
um yes that was right we've got some
quite strong words here coming from a
number of different
um members of or former members of the
military establishment Security Services
and as well as sort of experts and
intelligence matters all really speaking
out about their concern over a string of
incidents we've had recently first of
all there was a Zoella bravaman
um sending a message from her personal
email and that leading to her being
stacked under under his trust before
being swiftly reinstated under Richie
soon act but we've also had reports that
emerge today
um of Liz truss um having her phone
hacked as foreign secretary earlier this
summer
um of course incredibly worrying um the
fact that some of the messages that were
hacked included
um a sort of secret messages about
Ukraine messages between her and kwazi
quateng
um and for these sorts of messages to be
falling into the hands of potentially
um foreign Rogue States
um is of course a massive course for
concern these two incidents in a short
space of time
um so I think that's why we're having
just so many
um voices speak out against it and
really speak for the need of some kind
of shake-up or review to be done
um to really show ministers they can't
continue acting in in these kind of ways
yes so we move on to the the Metro where
lordanet has uh pictured there and the
the quotas that he's warning that voters
will punish such slackness our leaders
must be sufficiently disciplined to only
communicate through authorized means
which themselves are encrypted and are
secure uh frankly it's not good enough
if these people aspire to be in senior
positions positions of leadership
they've got to be disciplined they've
got to follow the rules or frankly will
put other people in their place I mean
you can't get harsher words than that
Rachel
yeah I'm not sure who the Wii is that
we'll put other other people in their
place perhaps he's referring to voters
but yeah yes I thought he was referring
to the public I think oh that's all
right then that's all right then yes
well that that's that's where that's
where the power to do that lies of
course
um I think that he's probably right that
voters would punish this sort of thing I
mean it is so sloppy isn't it and it is
really troubling
um when you look at the allegations that
were made about the the leaks of um the
fact that Liz truss's mobile phone was
compromised and the kind of information
that
um that would have been gained access to
because of that uh people are saying
most likely Russia but it could it could
be another country
um it's really like quite troubling
information
um highly confidential information that
could be used against the UK so of
course the public are going to see that
and think are they compromising our
security in some way okay and why is
there also that ministers just aren't
following
um the most basic protocol because it
isn't the case that they're unaware of
this
um you know most of the reporting is
saying that the protocols are in place
uh everybody is well aware of the
security that they need to follow what
they need to do so it does really beg
that question well why aren't they why
aren't they doing what they're supposed
to be doing around this very sensitive
issue that is the question let's move on
to the mail and this story about the
Migrant Center that came under attack in
Dover Camilla
um yeah so this is quite a shocking um
story based on
um events of today where three uh fire
bombs were thrown into this Dover
um facility that houses migrants and the
um attacker reportedly then went to a
practical station and and took his own
life so um a really shocking report
coming out there and also just the
latest
um in in a sort of series of
um worrying uh reports coming out of
these migrant centers
um we had the the news recently that in
a nearby facility in Kent
um there was an outbreak of Scabies and
and diphtheria because of the
overcrowding there so really some quite
significant issues going on in these
Asylum centers
um and something that both the home
office and sort of Border Force Police
really need to to get a grip on and
we've also had Tori MPS in in the local
areas speaking about the sort of the
rising tensions and the need to really
sort out what's going on with those
facilities because clearly um look at
having issues like overcrowding and
actually violent attacks on these
centers is something that the
authorities really need to get a grip on
staying with migrants but a different
story in the telegraph we'll move on to
now Rachel and this is the idea that
sowella bravaman is considering
um bringing forth a policy where
migrants will share hotels with members
of the public so they wouldn't be hotels
just dedicated to housing migrants
well you know obviously there's a real
problem there with how
um Asylum Seekers who are awaiting
processing
um where they're being made to wait and
so ever soiler Braverman was told that
she's illegally detaining essentially
Asylum seekers in these appalling
conditions these processing centers
um where as we've heard there's
outbreaks of infectious diseases and
people are just living in horrendous
conditions we're talking about families
we're talking about children who have
been have already you know been
traumatized and fleeing you know
unimaginable circumstances and so there
is that question of why aren't they
being uh put processed quicker why
aren't their claims being dealt with
faster so that actually they don't need
to wait for months on end in hotels
which isn't an ideal solution either
um lots of uh organizations that work
with refugees have very often often
criticized this policy of having
Asylum Seekers and refugees have to wait
for months on end in these very crowded
conditions in hotels and they just want
to start their lives they're also not
able they're not allowed to work or seek
employment while those the claims are
being processed so again making them
very more vulnerable so
Rachel we must leave it there and take
the break now Rich Lincoln thank you
very much for the moment that stay right
where you are coming up could Rishi
sunac you turn and go to the cop 27
climate Summit after all we'll be
discussing that next
foreign
[Music]
you are watching The Press preview still
with me Rachel shabby and Camilla Turner
there they are right on cue let us have
a look at the eye and it looks according
to the eye that the Prime Minister Rishi
sunak may be about to do a a massive
u-turn on whether he attends cop 27 or
not he could actually go along what do
we think to that Camilla
um yes so this story is about how um the
prime minister is now saying well his
his people are saying that he's prepared
to go to the cop 27 Summit after all
having previously said that he wasn't
going to go
um on the basis that his absolute
priority is the economy and he needs to
be in the UK so he can sort out the
preparations
um for the fiscal statement um which of
course is happening on um November 17th
having been pushed back from from the
Halloween uh budget that was meant to be
tomorrow
um so you know some people might say
that's fair enough you know that they're
dealing with the economy and and the
upcoming budget is is undoubtedly um the
most pressing need for for the British
um economy domestically
um however there are there have been a
lot of criticism people who think um it
sends the wrong signal if the UK isn't
sending their head of state and their
their you know most senior politician of
course you could send someone more
Junior but if they're not sending the
Prime Minister along to to this Summit
then it signals that it's not important
for the UK and we've had multiple um
voices
um coming out and criticizing Rishi
sunak not least his own climate Czar
alakshama
um saying that it um doesn't send the
right message also George Osborne the
the former Chancellor
um and and multiple others so we're now
getting a sort of a softening of stance
from Downing Street saying that if good
progress is made on the budget
um then there is a possibility Rishi
soon I could go along to this after all
yeah but the seeming change of direction
is coming after the paper reports are a
major they're calling it a major Tory
backlash and Senior government sources
are saying that he may go to Egypt as
you say good progress is made on fisc on
the fiscal statement but Rachel this is
just going to seem really weak isn't it
I think that's right yes I think what it
suggests to me is is bad political
instincts because how could he not have
known that first of all this would be
quite a big issue amongst his own party
but also that it's quite a big deal with
the public as well I mean we've just had
a un environment
um commission reports say that
there is now no path to getting on track
with climate uh climate emissions
Productions or to reduce Global heating
because the progress on that front has
been so weak and so bad and that all we
can do now is is try and mitigate the
the worst impacts of the climate crisis
clearly
um clearly this meeting next week in
Sharma is incredibly important I think
everyone understands the urgency of that
and yeah I think it does look weird that
Rishi sunak didn't really get that we
shall see because we hasn't you turned
yet so uh we shall see on that one just
very quickly you've got just under a
minute Camilla to tell us about Liz
trusses at Diva demands as a reported in
the Metro
um yeah so this is an extract from the
upcoming um book about this trust by um
the sun's political Edge to Harry Cole
it talks about
um the demand she had as foreign
secretary which included
um having multiple double espressos per
day
um asking for freshly prepared food
everywhere she went saying absolutely no
sandwiches and no mayonnaise
um also wanting a sauvignon blanc bottle
of wine every night um so really just
laying out in quite a lot of
excruciating details I think the 42 000
coffees a day is an overestimate though
um Camilla and Rachel thank you both for
taking us through the papers